so a round of applause please for Fabio
and
till thank
you okay thanks everybody um let's get
started let's see okay yeah great um so
I want to set a little bit the stage
before uh we dig de into the
implementation details and what we did
um and so I want to start with like you
know looking analyzing like a like a
really simple like machine learning
workflow where you basically have a
bunch of data static CSV files for
instance um and you read them up you
train a model and then you make
prediction and that's it kind of it
right um and that's fine um but that's
usually not the end goal um the end goal
is to build what we call a machine
Learning System right um the difference
between just a model and a machine
Learning System is that a machine
Learning System you get a on one side
data continuously getting updated you
may have like streaming data coming in
but even like you know daily batches or
hourly batches and on the other side you
have um you know you continuously have
to make predictions right again either
in real time or in in batches uh every
every now and then now if you look at
this one um you have a couple of
challenges that you need to sort out uh
if you want to implement a machine
Learning System right the first aspect
is to take care of like updates coming
in of the data right you have to
consider you know either appending new
data updating existing data um handling
data coming in at different rates from
this system systems and much more right
the second thing you want to do is you
want to look at you know retraining your
model and now and then uh depending on
the use case um data outside changes
your model needs to adapt a new data so
you have to have a situation where you
uh keep retraining your data every now
and then and the last part is that um
now you have a bunch of new context uh
that you can use to make better
predictions so you need to provide the
same context that you use for training
your model you need to do that when you
uh make predictions as well
so the way we solve this problem is by
in in two in two ways right so the first
part is um we break down what we have
like as a kind of Monolithic pipeline uh
into three different stages there you go
um the first stage would be a feature
pipeline which is you know just takes up
uh some row data confus features and
write them somewhere the second stage
would be uh a training pipeline which is
basically just um you know training your
model retri the features training your
model uh either in now secular mod model
pie torch whatever whatever it is and
the last part of the pipeline last step
would be an inference pipeline which is
basically saying I'm going to make
predictions either in real time or uh in
in batches this is the first step of
solving the problem the second problem
uh that we have is that if you look at
this one we need a wait for all the
three pipelines to communicate with each
other right we need a place to store the
state and that's um the V store so um
that's where kind of obor comes in um
the idea behind opor is provides a place
where you can actually store features um
and retrieve them for both training your
model and also for doing like inference
both real time and and batch and you
know AB extracts a bunch of metadata so
you can keep things consistent uh
throughout all the stages um all the
different
pipelines now under the op is
implemented uh has two essentially
storages essentially and like a metadata
layer in between the metadata layer
trucks and build up the UI um we have a
booth so you can come later and and see
the UI and see what you can do um but um
the other two aspects are the offline
data storage and the online data storage
right the offline data storage is what
powers all the um all the model training
and all the uh B predictions the online
data storage is what powers the real
time um inference essentially the online
uh the online storage is a realtime IM
memory database it's it's fast in
today's talk we're going to be focusing
only on the offlines part and how be uh
how we improved it um and uh and why we
did that so the reason we wanted to look
at performance of the offline part is
that if you look at OBS is not the only
feature store out there there are bunch
of other feature stores out there and if
you look at how they are implemented and
do there are two technologies that
really uh shine one is uh either built
on spark um or they are built on uh data
warehouse um either cloud or or or on
Prem um the problem with both
Technologies is that they are quite slow
like if you think spe specifically spark
takes 30 seconds just to start the
application and then you know get
another little bit of time to schedule
the executor and it's a minute as fast
and you have done no work at all um so
if you compare this one with the initial
workflow where you have static CSV file
trainer model and and and and off you go
it's much slower right so it provides
like a really worse kind of user
experience for python developer data
scientist so we want to improve that um
the way the feature store Works
essentially as said spark was used for
um essentially joining different
features together and passing them to
the either training pipeline or the
inference pipeline using the jdbc
protocol um jdbc is another source for
uh performance issues um and till is
going to dig in deta in details on why
um but essentially at the eye level what
we did is we replaced spark with dtb um
and the other thing we did was we
replace jtbc with outof flight um the
outfight protocol um this makes it
things a little bit like way more faster
not a little bit um and so now till is
going to um go into details on the
implementation details and and and
explain how we did it all right um yeah
first I want to talk about a bet P Arrow
um so a pach arrow is an inmemory data
format and um it has a columnar data
layout in memory so um that makes it
very optimized for analytical workloads
because data in the same column is close
to it close to each other in memory so
another feature of um Arrow uh of eror
is that you can do zero copy reads that
means you can um instead of loading the
data from pendas to uh to a certain file
and then read it back from uh with dctb
you can just uh read write a query in
dub that reads pendas data directly from
memory without any copying so um What er
the arrow framework itself or the arrow
package also features is a client server
framework so you can build uh arob based
data
services uh with this framework and you
can do for example something like uh you
have a backend service there are some
arot tables that can come from pet files
or from wherever and um you can send
them through the arof flight RPC
protocol to your uh client that is very
lightweight and lives in a in the python
process uh for example in a Jupiter
notebook and um the great thing about it
is that it's much faster than uh other
database networks prot uh Network
protocols like
jdbc um this a benchmark for example so
if you if you want to transfer uh 16
million rows from uh your server to your
client and um if you use odbc that takes
uh 70 seconds if you use Arrow flight
for this this only takes uh like a
couple of seconds and uh one of the
reasons is that the arrow flight
protocol doesn't break with the columna
data orientation of uh Arrow so um this
adds a lot of overhead if you have a
rowwise uh protocol like uh jdbc and
that's alleviated when you use um aof
flight um yeah so what is Dub uh DB is
an analytical database management system
so it's built to um to answer analytical
queries to your data uh it's lightweight
and it can run in process so that means
DB can run in your Jupiter notebook it
can run as part of your ETL script or it
can also run uh in your aror flight
server um
yeah and it's uh super fast so when you
look at the
benchmarks on this particular Benchmark
you're doing joints between tables of
100 million rows um five different
queries and dub can uh process them in
20 seconds and um spark takes 20 times
as much to do to answer the same
query um what it also features it
features larger than memory data process
ing so if your data set doesn't fit into
memory that's not a problem for dctb it
can offload intermediate results to disk
and um so it supports also various uh
data format storage connectors it's very
versatile in that sense and has lots of
useful ESL extensions uh for example the
S off join that we extensively use in
the feature
store um yeah and of course it also has
the zero copy integration with and
that's not only for reading but um you
can also materialize the query results
um right into an arrow
table um so in this example you create
an inmemory uh instance of dub and then
you read a pet file or you run a query
on the pet file so um and the query
result you will get back as an arot
table so um yeah I'm going to talk about
uh how this was all useful to basically
Implement our um dctb a flight power
feature
store um yeah the feature store is uh
using hops FS which is a file system
that was uh developed by hopworks uh
it's a distributed file system and it's
based on uh
htfs and uh the feature groups so the
different tables that contain uh
features are all stored in hoodie tables
in hoodie uh Lakehouse format in on this
distributed file system and um training
data sets so that combined different
features can also be stored on the same
uh on the uh hops FS file
system um usually we would have the um
the spark drop running that joins tables
and then it either sends them directly
back back to the U to a client in the
Jupiter notebook to uh um jdbc and
there's a es aty client in the in a
Jupiter notebook and the python process
or it materializes the result directly
to dis uh so others can consume it from
there and uh the idea is to basically
replace this part with dctb and aof
flight there are couple of challenges uh
uh that we faced or where we thought
okay will this work out uh one of them
is we need authenticated authorized
access to the server back end every
client has to authenticate itself um
what is really nice is that arof flight
also comes with uh mtls so everything is
uh is encrypted and also
authorized um the second thing is we
need to read from our hops FS file
system with dub and that worked actually
surprisingly simple because there is
this uh python package called fspc which
is a file system interface for Python
and dctb is compatible with that so by
only adding three lines of
code uh we can make dub read from hdfs
directly so we have that challenge uh
challenge solved now the next thing is
on this um hops FS file system there are
these hoodie tables and they are
basically pet files that are partitioned
into different folders partition based
on a partition key that the user defines
and it also keeps track of the data
changes over time so it's versioning
versioning the uh P files when someone
updates data in there it's a copy on
write
mechanism so we had to write some logic
to identify which of those pet files are
the uh representing the latest snapshot
version of the the table in there we did
that with a combination of hoodi
metadata and um file
names uh there's more on the blog post
there will also be a QR code of the blog
post later on I don't want to go into
too much detail on
that but we get these uh files that we
repres this pet files that represent our
tables and we just register them as
temporary tables in
dub and what you can do that you can
just run your query you can we can run
the query that constructs the training
data set on this temporary
tables uh in this example we are joining
a user table or user features with other
features um so and we filter this to
only users that live in the Netherlands
and in the ideal case the data would be
partitioned by country and so what we do
then when we identify the relevant path
in uh in hoodie we only we basically
push the filter to the file system level
and only uh register those paret files
that are actually relevant for the
filter that we have in the query
INB so um yeah and we use sof joints
which are really really uh relevant
feature for us because we always want to
make sure that the features the the user
features we are now join joing at the
other features we are joining onto the
user features that they're not leaking
information from the future into our
training data set and that's an
inequality join or an inequality join on
the IDS but an inequality join on a Time
s and that's something that is very very
difficult for databases to do
efficiently because if systems systems
don't optimize for that you will end up
with a cross product in memory and that
uh will explode so but this sof joint
feature exactly optimizes for this uh
case yeah the um last part how how do we
make this stable right this is system
that should run in production has
multiple users that come with different
queries we cannot really um anticipate
how large the queries are how large the
data sets are so on so what is necessary
than induct be to use this outof core
feature um so offload
um compute intermediates to disk is that
you set specify memory limit and also
specify temporary directory so and this
is all that dub needs to be able to
process n than memory
data second thing is because these
joints are quite large or the tables can
be large and we want to not stress the
server too much with getting multiple
requests with basically duct be having
to run multiple queries at the same time
so uh we have one server instance that
can run one query at a time we queue the
other requests because we don't want the
other clients to be waiting we just
replicate the aror flight server
instances and loads load balance between
them and with this and
over okay thanks um so after doing all
this work
uh we wanted to check like um how
obviously how fast this thing was and
how do how we compare with all the tools
out there right so the first thing we
did was to set up a benchmark using the
NYC taxi data set and we do we did a
little bit of a different Benchmark than
usual like as as still was explaining
when you are joining uh multiple
features from uh different feature pip
plans for uh creating a train data set
you don't just do a normal join you end
up doing what we call what we call what
it's called a poting Time joint right um
what essentially that means is that you
see the Red Dot is our prediction Target
is our label it's the time of the for
which the label is valid we want to join
the label with let's say Feature A and B
uh but as there are multiple updates
because data is coming in uh
continuously we want to make sure we
pick the values of those features that
were valid at the moment the uh
prediction Target was there right so
this creates a little bit of a complex
joint uh if you're expressing it in
spark if you're expressing in dctb uh
there is a there is a nice operator to
abstract away that complexity but
essentially we run two different uh two
different benchmarks right the first
Benchmark is basically retrieving all
the data into uh a pandas uh a pandas
data frame in the client um we compare a
bunch of other tools out there uh over
different um over different uh data set
sizes from 5 Millions all the way up to
50 million rows um and you can see there
are we are between like seven and 45
times
faster uh for the uh 10 million rows and
if you're using pure spark uh you won't
be able to like achieve the 20 million
and you won't be able to finish the 50
million either essentially right so
that's that's why you don't see any red
uh lines
there um the last part is uh as as Ste
was explaining uh OBS is an option to
materialize all the data set into uh
either Park files or CSV files um so we
run a benchmark also on that one here
spark managed to succeed for the 20
million row but he filed again at 50
million rows and again the DB solution
uh it's significantly faster than you
know other Solutions out there based on
either spark or or a data
warehouse so to conclude everything uh
this this new service uh kind of brings
the like a python interactive user
experience uh to the feature store so
people that were s that were used to
have a local workflow reading and
training models directly on on the local
P the local pandas uh data frame um they
can applicate that experience um using
using a fidget store um significantly
more uh significantly better performance
than uh other the solutions out there um
spark door is still an option if you
have like several terabytes data data
sets that you want to join together you
can still fall back to to to using a
spark workflow we will have to allocate
enough resources to get it running uh
but you know there is an the option is
still
there that being said um if you wanna if
you want to have a more in-depth version
of this talk like we wrote a blog post
as well you can scan the link here I
think there there's a channel on the uh
P slack where we going to post a slide
as well um so you can go through in
details about the actual implementation
as well and a little bit more in terms
of benchmarks and so
on I have to say if you're interested in
um working on these type of problems we
writing uh if you find find me and there
is a colle another of mine we have a
booth there uh it's the greenest thing
you could find in in the entire location
so you cannot not see us please come
talk to us and and we'll uh sort
something out the other thing I want to
mention um if you're interested in the
future stour space and so on we are
organizing a conference on it's online
it's on the 11th of October uh there are
bunch of speakers as being one of them
but you know a bunch of other companies
are presenting their solution and their
their their setup uh it's free so you
know you can just register
[Music]
um and that's that's about it um yeah if
you're again if you're interested and
talking more I guess we have time for
questions or again we have a we have a
booth out there and so you can come talk
to us during the event afterwards thank
you so much Fabio and T big round of
[Applause]
applause